all right my favorite position in all of
football is the receiver position my
favorite prospect among all receivers
entering this year's draft and i'm not
just saying that because i'm
interviewing him now is dk metcalf out
of mississippi and dk joins us today
thanks to old spice's all new fresher
collection featuring five new body
washes with real benefits forged by real
ingredients like moisturization and
exfoliation because old spice knows that
men have skin too available at
walmart dk got a big change in your life
coming up in a couple of days how you
feeling about what's to come i'm feeling
very anxious and excited just to be here
and look it has to be
both exciting and nerve-wracking because
you have no control over this process
you're going to get a phone call on
thursday night from a team that is going
to draft you whether you want to live
there or not play there or not what kind
of what kind of emotions do you feel as
you enter into this unknown as to where
it is going to be that you're going to
be living and working for the next four
or five years
um i mean i can i i don't i'm not going
in there with high expectations or
uh wanting to go somewhere so um you
know whatever team drafts me um they're
just going to get
you know a hard working player um
that's that's just ready to play
football again
dk what's the best advice you've gotten
as to what you can expect or should
expect at the next level
um just to keep working hard and just um
you know feel feel any void
uh that's needed by the team um whether
it's special teams whether it's just go
in going in just running a deep route
being a decoy blocking so i'm just
trying to go in and just you know feel
any void that's needed by the team
you know it's critical in football to
have confidence what part of your game
are you most confident about
uh getting off press and then going deep
i feel like nobody can stop me when i
have a go route post route
come back any of those routes i feel
like i'm the best
how much press coverage did you face in
college
uh
i faced a pretty good amount
um probably from almost every team
and and uh
have you gotten an idea of
you know what it's going to be like to
face press coverage when you're dealing
with an nfl caliber defensive back have
you gotten any work in that regard have
you gotten any specific advice on how
different it's going to be getting off
the line of scrimmage at that level
oh yes sir i've gotten some advice of
how they're going to play me
and then uh just playing in the sec
um i feel like that that's gotten me
more ready
for the next level than anything but i
know at the next level you know they're
just going to be a step better a step
quicker uh that much smarter
um than
the dbs in the sec so i'm just ready to
take on that challenge
well and one thing that helps you you've
got the size you've got the strength
you've got the physique to pull it off
to do battle hand to hand with those
defensive backs and you've created a lot
of buzz for the shape that you're in and
there was a suggestion that your body
fat is only one point six percent
somebody said it's impossible that
anyone's body fat percentage could be
that low do you know the actual number
of your body fat percentage
yes it was 1.9
oh it's 1.9 okay well okay
so one point
one point six a little bit off 1.9 is
the magic number for dk metcalf's body
fat percentage what do you what do you
give me your because i could use a
little lab work give me your best three
ab exercises to get as ripped as you are
um
they call rebel abs um like six inches
crunches and then uh you hold both of
them uh for a minute so
um in track my track coach had me do abs
almost every day so
i just used that ab workout
and as your abs got stronger as your
core got stronger how did you feel that
translated into your football game
um i could run forever
and then my my balance was pretty good
uh just coming from my core work so i
just kept doing abs
what's your favorite pass route to run
i go out
why
four three three
yes yes sir if i can
beat the defender off the line i don't
have to worry about him anymore
when you ran that four three three at
the con by me what were you expecting to
generate that day
um i thought i was gonna run a 438-435
um i did not expect to get uh below that
um but after i did you know i just thank
god for the opportunity thank god
because you know without him
um i wouldn't be able to do that so um i
was just after that enjoying the moment
with my family just ready to get back on
and let's go back to the go route when
you run 40 yards in a straight line you
don't have to worry about anybody
knocking you off the ball you don't have
to worry about looking for a ball are
there some nuances to because people
just think you just go right go route
nine routes straight down the field give
me an idea of what some of those details
are that people may not realize
you know watching a game on tv as to how
what it takes to get open
when you're when your assignment is
simply go straight down the field
um people don't realize that there's a
defender in front of you that you have
to manipulate or
try to get low and
uh try to trick them with your footwork
so um you know people don't see that
my feet are quick and i can get off
press coverage uh whenever i want to
so you know i just let the people talk
how much does the quarterback factor in
whether and to what extent it's going to
take you time to get off of press
coverage because if they jam you up for
a little bit it throws off the timing of
the whole play
right um so the quarterback has to see
where i'm at and throw a perfect ball
you know over the outside shoulder to
where only i can catch it or nobody
catches it so the quarterback plays a
big role in uh in that too
the uh you know the question always
comes up for the prospects in the draft
are you the best at your position the
answer is always yes so i'll assume your
answer is yes but i want you to tell me
what makes you the best receiving
prospect in the 2019 draft class
um
because of what i did at the combine and
then you know i feel like i can run
routes i can block and i can catch the
ball
um
so
there's no other complete receiver than
me in my mind
what's the question you got most often
from the teams that that spoke to you in
the weeks leading up to the draft
um probably about my injuries in uh
college
they asked what did you say
what what would be your explanation or
or what the information they wanted from
you as to the injuries that you suffered
um they're just freak injuries and could
happen to anybody
playing this sport but um you know i'm
i'm not injury prone or
any of that
and i'm just going to take care of my
body at the next level
is there a criticism of your game at the
college level that bugs you that you
think is unfair
um people saying that i had a limited
router
what what how how far does your route
tree go beyond the go route
uh a goal post
a curl
that's pretty much all we ran
is there one specific route that you
know you're going to need to work on to
to run it the way they're going to
expect you to run at the nfl level
probably the outro because
i just stick and i don't explode out i
just kind of like coached out so
probably the hour out
what receivers currently playing in the
nfl or that ever have played in the nfl
do you try to pattern yourself after
um the big receivers who can run as well
like julio calvin johnson and uh randy
moss
have you gotten advice from any of these
guys who have really done it at a high
level in the nfl as to what you need to
do to be like them
no sir i really haven't uh talked to
anybody
guys who have played at mississippi that
are at the next level any guys that
you've been working with
who may be back in school you have a
relationship with them like a la crosse
quan treadwell guys who can help you
understand what you're going to be
getting yourself into when you head to
the nfl
uh derek jones he was a cornerback at
the jets
gave me a lot of tips
um dante moncrief who's now the receiver
for the steelers
um he told me about uh press coverage
and you know the process
of leading up to the draft and you know
after the draft and then um evan ingram
uh has gave give me a lot of tips on you
know what to do when i get there
you're going to the draft on thursday
night in nashville what what are you
expecting that evening to be like for
you
um i'm really not expecting anything i'm
just gonna go in and whatever happens
happens uh just gonna let god take care
of it i'm just gonna gonna enjoy uh the
time of my family
do you have a range high and a low where
you you think maybe that's where you may
end up going
uh no sir no expectations at all
when that phone rings what do you think
your reaction is gonna be
i'm probably gonna bless out to cry
just knowing all of my hard work is just
it's going to pay off
and um
i i know that you've said before and and
and you have no choice but to say you're
going to go wherever you get drafted but
would you kind of prefer that maybe to
stay a little closer to home not go
quite so far away to start off your nfl
career it doesn't matter to you
no sir it really doesn't matter to me
because i know my family's going to be
there regardless
well uh dk we appreciate some of your
time as you get ready to embark on what
should be a very exciting journey we're
rooting for you and we can't wait to see
you run the go route and every other
route at the nfl level and uh we thank
old spice for giving us some of your
time today all the best on thursday
night we look forward to talking to you
down the road yes sir thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports